ho ho ho and happy horror days scream
fans and welcome to the special
Christmas edition of bloodline you know
Jordan this time of year people like a
warm and fuzzy movie like say it's a
wonderful life which I've never seen but
no not us we like our horror serve year
round yeah so we have curated list of
top 10 christmas themed horror movies
yes to get you through all this holiday
cheer homicidal maniac is loose at
Christmas number 10 on the list don't
open till Christmas this one turns at
rope around a little bit if Santa's
being killed instead of doing the
killings so budget it's bad it is too
awesomely terrible to miss number nine
the children this just confirms what you
already know the worst part about
Christmas your relatives 20 minutes into
this movie you will appreciate your
drunk people weighing in at number 8
Jack Frost a horror comedy from the
1990s that lands on this list pretty
much entirely because the pre American
Pie Shannon Elizabeth epic death match
between her and an abominable snowman in
shower number seven silent night zombie
night kasam bees make everything better
this is more of a love triangle between
a cop his wife and his partner and in
the end love conquers all okay that's
not true zombies care about knife in the
face not love number six we have Sint
released in the united states as Saint
Nick it is a Dutch story that tells the
tale of center cloths present national
who descends upon Amsterdam every year
in a ship from Spain and this time he's
brought with him an army of his
assistant black Peter to take away all
those who have done naughty works five
Silent Night deadly night part of the
Canon you gotta have it unless it is the
Santa slasher movie boy has traumatic
experience comes back reap vengeance on
people as an adult I mean I didn't love
it but it's gotta go on the lesson
important
no trying to my Christmas sliding at
number four is wind to a
high-maintenance coed hitches a ride
home for the holidays with a guy who
turns out to be her stalker but it's not
the stalker she needs to worry about it
is the icy conditions on this dangerous
stretch of road and then number three
Christmas evil which actually turned out
to be once you get past the camp a
pretty compelling serial killer profile
this one is actually John Waters
favorite Christmas horror movie of all
time and coming in at number two is rare
exports a christmas tale this takes
place in a small town where a mining
project unearths evil Santa and his army
of L and at number one my ultimate
favorite that Nels scares and Christmas
camp Black Christmas this is a bunch of
sorority girls who are being terrorized
by a nihilistic killer and you will be
afraid to answer your phone after you
watch this alone and not go wrong so
that's it for this holiday special of
bloodline watch these movies after you
put the kids to bed yeah and if you have
any Hanukkah horror recommendations
because they were like none ya do email
us at bloodline at wired.com because
we'd love to hear about them and as we
like to say you're in bloodline happy
holidays
you